caffeinated popcorn and corn dog
flavored chapstick it's episode five of
the loot if you've got four thousand
dollars in 12 months the cheeky calm
will wait for a farm-raised piglet to
die of natural causes and then taxidermy
it into an actual piggy bank do you want
to season your food and to be a fairy
princess will these salt and pepper
shakers our wands but if you want to
play with Legos and shoot guns check out
books on how to build working Lego
shooting guns out of Legos this item was
submitted by a Vsauce err just like you
and you can do the same over at
facebook.com slash vsauce gaming if
you're tired of all this newfangled
technology dress up your iphone in a
1980s cell phone skin and here's a mask
you can buy that attracts hummingbirds
and contains a sugary solution so you
can get one to fly right next to your
face if you get hurt bandaged it like
comic book punches with BAM POW wham and
more but let's get super geeky sanguine
Griffins sells yarn and patterns stand
it outfits like this one inspired by
Moby Dick and these socks covered in
text from Beowulf luna and curious as a
necklace made of a handcuffed bear and
the neato shop hasbro a girlfriend which
expands to six times its size and water
which is what she said then warm up the
water and brew some tea with tea bags
that tea bag and to avoid losing things
while sipping wedge stuff into this
couches grid of tight slots while
lounging play xbox with one of caliber
11s incredible console vaults and after
gaming for eight hours straight convince
your friends you were actually with a
girl the whole time with these temporary
tattoos that look like kick-ass hickeys
the same site offers illusion stickers
you can put on your luggage I love this
busted tees Venn diagram shirt and we've
all seen the classic tuxedo t-shirt but
for those of us who are even more cash
they bring the disheveled tuxedo shirt
still not dressed down enough by a
wife-beater that says I think about
farting on you all the time
speaking of shirts pick up this Chewie
and Han mashup or a duct-tape shirt if
you're beyond t-shirts and you're a girl
grab an official sexy Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle costume my favorite is
Michelangelo or if you prefer making
sandwiches in the kitchen grab an apron
from Bethany so and so she makes Wonder
Woman Batgirl Supergirl mrs. incredible
and more in the last episode of loot
xoxo Jenny goo xoxo mentioned that I
didn't include any Rubik's cubes but no
need to fear because today I bring you
my collection first of all I've got a
lot of cool weird cubes as well as the
you know original three by three by
three
I've got Rubik's is four five and the V
Cube six by six by six as well as feet
cubes totally cool and seven by seven by
seven my collection is still growing
though I've got my eye on the gear wheel
iq cube this Rubik's Cube mug and in the
last couple of days the new world record
seventeen by seventeen by seventeen cube
be sure to subscribe to Vsauce 2 for
more the bigger it gets the better and
as always thanks for watching
[Music]